welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of X-Men
Origins Wolverine the fourth installment
of our X-Men stick stick rewatch as we
break down all 13 of the fox X-Men and
Deadpool films ahead of Wolverine's
mutant Homecoming in Deadpool 3 in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as the first
X-Men film to release after the dawn of
the MCU Origins represents a departure
from the three preceding X-Men films but
it set Wolverine on his own odd
trajectory leading to Logan in his
coming rematch with Ryan Reynolds Wade
Wilson which begins in this movie so
let's break down Xmen Origins Wolverine
scene by scene and if you want to avoid
any potential Deadpool 3 spoilers I will
leave all of that for our Danger Room
section at the end of this video and to
celebrate this X-Men Snick Snick rewatch
we are doing a special X-Men themed
merch release which is really the best
way to support new rock stars grab one
of these designs by clicking the link in
the description okay this is the first
X-Men film where the X in the opening
20th Century Fox logo does not linger
longer than the other letters it's our
first indication that this movie is
going to be a bit different from the
previous ones David benof co-creator of
Game of Thrones was one of the writers
of this film along with skip Woods who
wrote swordfish which starred Hugh
Jackman and Halle Berry we open on the
Northwest Territories Canada 1845 on
Victor Creed young saber-tooth whittling
his long fingernails into sharp claws as
he sits at the bedside of his friend
James howlet who hasn't yet adopted the
name Logan or Wolverine James is played
by Troy Savon a Canadian actor and
singer songwriter who roast to fame on
YouTube recently parody by Timothy
shalamay on Saturday Night Live I know
Trac Cody Smith MC actually was
originally cast in this role but it
conflicted with him shooting the road
actually Cody Smith MC would later play
Nightcrawler in X-men apocalypse before
freaking us out in the power of dogs so
James is sick in bed around 8 years old
here this is 1845 and considering the
first X-Men movie came out in 2000 and
was set in a not too distant future
which we think was somewhere around 2003
that would make Logan around 150 years
old when we first met him in that movie
indeed older than you professor and
older than Hank McCoy when he called him
boy in The Last Stand we see a
silhouette picture of a wolverine on the
wall next to the bed as John dotes on
James Victor gives the exchange the stin
eye he seems to know or at least suspect
that his own dad who would never dot on
him like this is actually James's
biological father and right on Q Thomas
Logan shows up hollering away in the
comics he was a drunk who abused his son
dog Victor is taking the place of dog
Logan here and it's probably why he
later says that his dad deserved what he
got the trauma of seeing his father Jon
die is what causes james' mutant powers
to manifest for the first time so that
he will never get sick like this again
and his claws have emerged this is where
he learns that Thomas Logan is his
biological father and X2 pyro told
Bobby's parents that males carry and
pass on the mutant Gene and while this
is never confirmed in the comics or the
movies the fact that both Thomas' sons
are mutants gives it some credibility
James's claws are bone claws not yet in
case and or fused with ad mantium in the
woods right before Victor tells James
that their brothers James notices
Victor's now sharp fingernails so we get
this great Montage over the opening
credits saber-tooth was played by Tyler
m in the first X-Men but he was recast
now to live shriber when shriber was
initially cast some people were a little
wary about whether or not he was big
enough to play the role he's 6'3 but but
whereas main was a wrestler with a
wrestler's Bill triber definitely wasn't
he recently described talking with Hugh
Jackman after getting the role I went to
Hugh and I I said there's a suit right
and he's like what do you mean he's I
was like cuz you know the muscles and
everything that's that's not real is it
he's like a mate you got to you got to
work out shriber ended up training with
Jackman in gaining 40 lbs for the rooll
in another interview he said I started
this program this four-month
weightlifting chicken genocide that was
really intense and I hope I never have
to do it again Victor and James fight
over many decades through several Wars
and I love how the Montage uses them
running as transitions keep on running
don't look back in the 1860s they fight
in the American Civil War on the union
side because they were from Canada
Victor now has facial hair very similar
to his father's bullets have no effect
on either of them and even a cannonball
blasts James in the chest and then on
that boom boom we are now in World War I
in the trenches the two are now fighting
back toback in a move that they will
revisit throughout the movie and then
they're fighting in World War II James
chomping down on Wolverine signature
cigar in a D-Day invasion at Normandy
now in the Comics Wolverine and Captain
America had some World War II adventures
together this movie came out in 2009
while the first Captain America film was
in development at Marvel Studios that
movie considered including cameos of
Wolverine as a p in Nazi occupied France
but that never came to be as Marvel
Studios looks to include their own
version of the X-Men in the MCU
continuity perhaps the trickiest part is
going to be including the classic origin
of characters like Magneto as a World
War II Holocaust Survivor if the present
day of the MCU is now supposed to be
sometime in the mid to late 2020s n
would have to be at least in his late
80s but it could be that just a version
of the X-Men history could have existed
in the MCU but maybe Wanda maximoff put
everyone in a post house ofm no more
mutants reality warp I'm kind of working
on a theory video about this currently
and also you should remember in the year
2009 X-Men Origins Wolverine was not the
only superhero movie to include opening
titles that plac gritty superheroes in
real world 20th century history because
a few months before this film released
Zack Snider's Watchmen would open with
an R-rated version of this very same
concept even down to the image of the
comedian with a cigar in Vietnam and the
iian like Victor does in this Montage
attacking a Vietnamese woman this one
with Wolverine and saber-tooth totally
holds up it's awesome to see after
surviving the firing squad Logan and
Victor are kept Shackled In The Dirty
cell from the hash marks on the wall
they have been here for a month major
William Striker introduces himself he
was played by Brian Cox and X2 and here
since he's younger he's played by Danny
Houston by X2 Striker had worked his way
up to the position of Colonel Striker is
adapted from Reverend striker in the
comics who's a religious fanatic and
tell evangelist at writer Chris
Claremont based on Jerry paulwell Senor
apparently Brian Cox had Express
interest in reprising the role for this
film using the same daging technology
that they' used on Patrick Stewart and
Ian McKellen in The Last Stand but this
was deemed too expensive to pull off
notice there's a rat playing on Victor
which shows him as a more animalistic
creature than Logan is director Gavin
Hood stated that the theme of the film
is Wolverine trying to balance the
animal aspect of the self with the human
aspect Victor shows what happens when
someone like Wolverine Embraces the
animal over the human on the wall behind
Victor a smiley face scratched into it
he no doubt did this with his long
disgusting nail claws like the smiley
face he will claw into the bar top later
now remember in X2 when Charles Xavier
pointed out that for someone who hates
mutant Striker keeps some strange
company Striker responded they serve
their purpose as long as they can be
control and here he recruits these guys
for a mission putting together a special
team with special
privileges now tell me how would you
like to really serve your country yes
shades of Nick Fury recruiting Tony
Stark building a team but notice the
reactions of both men as Striker makes
his pitch your boys tired of
running tired of denying your true
nature
what do you care oh I
care I care because I know how special
you are how
valuable Striker is manipulating them
from minute one and when he tells them
that they're special Victor perks up
almost hopefully whereas James size and
practically rolls his eyes Victor was
raised with an abusive father whereas
James was raised with a loving one so
James knows what genuine care looks like
and he knows this ain't it Victor just
wants a daddy figure to tell him that
he's special and this is what lets
Striker know that he's going to be the
easier one of the two to outright
manipulate the guys join the special
Task Force Team X we actually first hear
Wade Wilson's blades as the camera
lingers on James and notice that the
noise of him sharpening his blade sounds
a lot like wolverines Adam antium Claus
anytime they come
out in the comics team X was made up of
Wolverine and Victor Creed and a few
others but here it consists of Wolverine
saber-tooth Wade Wilson played by Ryan
Reynolds a skilled swordsman who later
becomes this movie's regrettable
Deadpool Agent Zero K Maverick from the
comics an expert Marksman played by
Daniel Henny John wraith a teleporter
played by Will I of the Blacky pe's Fred
Dukes AKA The Blob but played by Kevin
Durant and Chris Bradley AKA bolt with
powers of electric current manipulation
played by Dominic monagan who had had a
banger of a few years coming off of Lost
and the Lord of the Rings films Ryan
Reynolds was super passionate about the
Deadpool character and when he heard
Wade Wilson was going to be in this
movie he asked to play the part
apparently at the time he was one of
only two stars to ever be cast in a
Marvel movie without auditioning the
other one being wle Snipes his blade his
role was originally just going to be a
cameo but it was made bigger once
Reynolds came on board thank you to
better help for sponsoring St in this
video A new year is a great excuse for
finally tackling the stuff that you put
off last year and if one of the things
you've been putting off until 2024 is
taking proper care of your mental health
better help can help you get started and
hey no judgment for waiting starting
therapy can be hard and the right
therapist for you might not be in your
area and some people struggle with the
face-to-face interaction of therapy with
better help you can have your therapy
sessions as a phone call as a video chat
or even via messaging if you prefer that
whatever is the most comfortable version
of therapy for you just click the link
in the description and answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preference
are better help will then match you with
the therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who is
in your network or anything like that if
you think you might benefit from therapy
consider better help click the link in
the description or visit betterhelp.com
rockstars clicking that link helps
support this Channel and also gets you
10% off your first month of better help
so you can connect with a therapist to
see if it helps you Willam got this role
in the film because he had said he
wanted to play a mutant with abilities
similar to Nightcrawler John wraith is
actually one of the more faithful comic
to movie members of Team X he has
similar teleportation powers to his
comic book self and he looks pretty
similar even rocking his trademark
cowboy hat The Blob is eating during
this flight setting up his weight gain
later on he's a big X-Men villain who
has indestructible skin and is actually
in League with Magneto Kevin Durand like
Dominic monan was known during these
years for his role on Lost as the cruel
KY David Harbor actually had a meeting
to play this role but apparently the
producers saw him without a shirt on and
they were like worried for his health
David Harbor later joked I was too fat
to play The Blob striker tells Bradley
to take the plane
down
oh you going to puke if we meant to fly
we'd grow wings several characters the
X-Men Universe have the ability to fly
including Angel who we saw with his
white Wings in The Last Stand Agent Zero
says don't worry Nancy more people di
driving and flying how about from
impaling foreshadowing Zero's death
later on right after his helicopter
crashes the team sits down in losos
Nigeria yes this city was the same
location in Captain America Civil War
where W maximoff accidentally blew up a
building during a mission an event at
the UN used as an excuse to pass the
sovia Accords and everyone shows off
their powers as they make it into this
building the elevator music is Tie a
yellow ribbon around the old oak tree
which is a song about someone who has
done their time in the military and
wants to know if he'll be welcomed home
by his love telling her to tie a yellow
ribbon around the tree so he'll know if
he should get off the bus or move on and
yes a cutaway to Super people in an
elevator a gag we saw in Spider-Man 2
and we would later see in Spider-Man no
way home meanwhile Wade runs his mouth
as he always does you're up next thank
you sir you look really nice today it's
the green brings out the seriousness in
your eyes oh my god do you ever shut up
pal no not when I'm awake it's cool to
see how many of his acting choices for
this first appearance as Wade Wilson
that Ryan Reynolds will carry on to his
eventual solo films as Deadpool the fast
clip talking the dead pants sarcasm the
instant comebacks and we get to see an
awesome sequence of his sword work which
ends with him slicing a bullet in half
so that it kills two guys behind him now
I have a feeling a lot of the moves from
this movie might get called back in
Deadpool 3 as it is technically the
first time Logan and Wade meet on screen
and while I'm sure a lot of these moves
will be jokes this move here is legit
and I hope it comes back cuz it's pretty
cool Striker lays the groundwork for
Wade's appearance at the end of the film
you didn't have that mouth on you Wade
You' be the perfect Soldier so the actor
playing the man in charge of the diamond
operation is hakee Kai kazim another
cast member from Lost and the voice of
tachaka in the animated Avengers Earth's
Mightiest Heroes so when Striker goes to
the small village the Villager says the
rock he's been asking about came from
the sky and James says that the man that
they're questioning is telling the truth
and the Comics Wolverine is basically a
lie detector he uses his heightened
senses to hear an increased heartbeat
and observe other signs of someone
trying to lie to him kind of like
Daredevil does and of course adamantium
is made for mixing steel with what kids
vibranium which comes from meteorites
like the one Striker is seeking out so
the word vibranium is not spoken in this
movie that's what this meteorite is made
out of when James quits the team he
takes off its dog tags and throws him
down a disgust he'll later get
replacement tags that read Wolverine the
ones we saw him with when he first
appeared in X-Men a deleted scene would
have shown a young storm Aurora Monroe
here as one of the
villagers
Jimmy Jimmy now again X-Men Origins
Wolverine came out when Kevin Fig's
independent Marvel Studios was still in
its phase one discovering that their
half a billion dollar loan from Merl
Lynch to fund Iron Man was paying off in
Spades but among the characters that
they put up as collateral to maril Lynch
were doctor strange and black panther
and Kevin fige wanted to introduce black
panther earlier in the MCU but the
Marvel CEO at the time ik prut didn't
believe that black and female
superheroes could sell as toys and he
shut him down which was stupid but at
the time Marvel Studios was an
independent studio and could have
partnered with Fox before Disney bought
them they considered a future team up
with the studio so along with these
World War II parallels between cap and
Wolverine there were some hopes back in
these years that Fox's X-Men continuity
might have been able to give Marvel
Studios an opportunity to set up things
like wakanda and black panther so cut to
the Canadian Rockies six years later
assuming Logan spent a few years on team
X after 1973 this would put us in the
early 80s but for a movie presenting
itself as a period piece there doesn't
seem to be much of a budget for period
specific props and costumes most of the
film it's like set in remote areas James
is now going by Logan which was the last
name of his biological father and he's
working as a lumberjack and living with
Kayla Silver Fox played by Lynn Collins
In The Wolverine Comics run Silver Fox
and Logan were in a relationship when
Silver Fox was killed by saber-tooth
this turned out to be a false memory
from a memory implant given to him by
The Weapon X Program in Wolverine Volume
2 number 62 that issue also had a
previous member of the team X dying
leading to questions about Wolverine's
past and conflict with saber-tooth so
this movie definitely Drew inspiration
from it Silver Fox was eventually killed
by saber-tooth for real though and
Wolverine buried her by their cabin in
the Canadian Rockies in the comics she
had retractable claws in the ability to
heal although not as well as Wolverine
this movie decided to give her more
unique powers Chris Bradley now works at
a carnival this may have been inspired
by the blob's original appearance all
the way back in Uncanny X-Men number
three The Blob originally worked at a
carnival where he used to challenge
Carnival goers to try to move him and he
would use his powers to resist Bradley
does something similar here with just
this simple light bulb trick he wears an
on the no t-shirt that reads power to
the people and a l bulb on it his room
in his trailer is filled with electrical
toys that he can play with these are all
real vintage toys there's robot liliput
a 1950s Charlie Weaver bartender toy
there's a symbol monkey and I love how
when Victor enters his head brushes
against the light bulbs hanging from the
ceiling it's a great visual reminder
just how much bigger he is than Bradley
and where's a carnival goer from earlier
dropped the light bulb when it got too
hot Victor hangs on to this one on
Bradley's screams all the power at the
carnival goes out showing that he was
really powering the whole thing Logan
wakes up from a nightmare with his claws
out so to the first X-Men film when he
stabbed Rogue although here his claws
only scratched Caleb and X-Men he was
having nightmares about his weapon x
procedure this makes it clear that he
had a tortured mind long before he was
experimented on there's a lot of like
Wolverine screaming up at the sky in
this movie director Gavin Hood wanted to
give the character PTSD from his W dayss
but Fox thought that that might be too
heavy when Striker shows up at Logan's
job Agent Zero mocks him for making
18,500 a year which at the end of the
70s would amount to about
$777,500 today and that's really not
that bad strike goes right into
manipulation mode Bradley was killed 3
days ago wait before
that I believe that someone is hunting
down our old team at this point Wade is
already being turned into Deadpool
somewhere in the lab right so Striker is
lying on so many levels it's never
really clear why he had Victor kill
Bradley since his power is cool but by
no means necessary to give to Deadpool
so I'm guessing he did it just to be
able to tell James he's dead I mean
maybe Deadpool has like electric current
manipulation Powers we just don't see
him use them on the way home unbeknownst
to Logan Silver Fox uses her powers to
diffuse intense situation with this
douchebag she has the ability of taaco
hypnosis meaning she can hypnotize
anyone she touches there's a kind of
dreamy mysterious musical cue that plays
when she's touching the sky your
boyfriend's got a big mouth I know big
temper too so please let us
pass she's touching Logan too in the
scene but she's definitely refusing to
influence him in the same way because as
she says he was the one who decided to
get out of the car she tells him this
story about the moon why is the moon so
long only
why cuz she used to have a lover a his
name was quatu and they lived in the
spirit world together that's a true
story she goes on to say that quatu and
the moon would wander the skies together
but another Spirit a trickster was
jealous and tricked qu katsu which she
says translates to the Wolverine
tricking them into leaving the spirit
world forever and every night he looks
up at the moon and howls and can never
touch her again this is actually based
on a real Native American Legend in the
comics Silver Fox is a member of the
Blackfoot tribe this story has several
parallels of the movie both the he could
never touch her line because silver
Fox's Powers come from touch and Logan
howling at the sky in the next scene
when he finds her body and assumes she's
dead and this is a story that inspires
him to get Wolverine on his name tags I
think we can admit in retrospect it's
not great that Logan mispronounces it by
referencing The Beatles cuu and he takes
an animal from this Legend to inspire
his moniker but you know it was 2009 and
even in 2024 we're only now getting like
coh 40 and what if in Echo but in a
series that Disney still had not enough
faith in so that they butchered into a
Kingpin show but it is interesting to
note that we're just led to believe that
Kayla is killed but of course we don't
actually see her get clawed and notice
how she even has just this look of
resignation on her face when her car
pulls up to Victor Logan catches up to
Victor scratching a comedian Smiley into
the wood of the bar and they fight
Victor throws Logan into the way of a
moving truck and that truck just hits
him and keeps right on trucking like
dude doesn't even pause I guess he's on
a schedule Logan sees Striker at the
hospital why didn't you tell me he was
Victor I didn't know I swear on my son's
life I didn't in X2 we actually saw that
Striker Sun means nothing to him so
obviously this is a false promise he's
using his son for horrible things Logan
agrees to undergo the weapon x procedure
to make himself into more of a weapon to
get his revenge on saber-tooth this
origin is pretty different from the
comics in the comics Striker was really
never part of the weapon x program and
Wolverine was abducted into it as
opposed to like volunteering for it
Striker says I can't put Victor down
myself Logan to kill him
going to have to embrace the other side
become the animal several times
throughout the film Silver Fox tells
Logan that he's not an animal so once
again we get these two Waring sides
within him right now he's choosing the
animal Striker explains to the generals
that the X and Weapon X is for the Roman
numeral 10 in the comics Captain America
was weapon one Logan's transformation
scene Bears a lot of similarities to
Steve Rogers undergoing the super
soldier serum procedure that turn them
into Captain America the other weapons
in this lineage are Brute Force as
Weapon 2 which was a collection of
augmented animals including a with
Wolverine claws it' be hilarious for
those guys to show up in Deadpool 3
weapon three was Harry piser AKA
skinless Man weapon four was man thing
who we just saw in werewolf F Knight in
the MCU weapon five is Project Venom
weapon six is Luke Cage who is now
technically part of the MCU weapons
seven is Frank Simpson AKA nuke who
based on his involvement in the Jessica
Jones series is also technically part of
the MCU and weapons eight and nine were
projects that created sleeper assassins
and then of course we meet weapon 11
Deadpool in this movie the doctor
performing the preced procure is Carol
Frost she was created for this film but
it's unclear if she's supposed to have
any relation to Emma Frost and Emma does
show up later in this movie that has the
same Diamond hard skin as Emma Frost
does in X-Men first Class but this
character is Kayla's sister named Emma
silverfox although it seems like at one
point they were supposed to be the same
person right this is totally Emma Frost
power set producer Lauren Scher Doner
later said that the Emma at the end of
this film isn't Emma Frost but I think
they just didn't want to commit to this
person being emros because Matthew vaugh
was at the same time developing X-Men
first Class where January Jones plays a
version of Emma Frost in the 1960s
either way it's confusing the shots of
Wolverine in the Pod as the adamantium
bonds to him is reminiscent of the comic
art of Marvel presents Weapon X Comics
which depict the same moment during the
procedure he flashes back through his
life all the moments we've already seen
including an ending on Kayla I love you
you're not an animal he is doing what
the doctor told him to do to hold on to
the reason he's doing this even as the
pain becomes unbearable even though he's
just had a hell of a time Logan's extra
sensitive hearing kicks in we taking him
to the
Island the Island
now the bonding
Works will use his DNA for the
11 he racist memory upon his Escape he
carves what letter into the door with
his new claw x and then he fugitive
jumps off the waterfall naked Logan runs
to a barn belonging to this elderly
couple Travis and Heather Hudson they
are a reference to Vindicator and
guardian two members of alphaflight a
Canadian superhero group who Wolverine
allies with at one point and since this
is a movie executive produced by lawren
Don and Richard Donner doesn't this kind
of feel like Jonathan Martha Kent
driving back to their Farm the sticker
on their truck reads not all who wander
are lost this is a quote from Jr tolken
Fellowship of the Ring from the riddle
of Aragorn a character who Bears more
than a few similarities to Wolverine but
it also reminds us of the quote from
Charles Xavier in Days of Future Past
that later gets echoed in Multiverse of
Madness just because someone stumbles
loses their way it doesn't mean they're
lost forever just because someone
stumbles and loses their way doesn't
mean they're lost forever in the
bathroom examines his new adamantium
claw and this is where the movie got a
lot of flack because they just do not
look as good here as they did in the
previous three films despite the fact
that the CGI technology was totally
Advanced at this point but in the first
three they were shinier they were often
practical and you could see reflections
of images in them as he moved making
them feel more authentic and real here
they just kind of look flat they almost
look like Styrofoam and they look like a
video game there are a lot of Threads
Online trying to figure out why exactly
they look this bad but no one's come to
a consensus it likely just came down to
the fact that the bfx team didn't have
enough time money but for my view it
really comes down to the two things I
mentioned in the Last Stand breakdown
context and character notice how his
claws now snicked up from the bottom of
the frame and they are visually detached
from the skin of his knuckles whereas in
the first Xmen the first time we see
them they are piercing through the
knuckle skin and shortly after this we
hear how Logan talks about how it hurts
every time but in this movie it doesn't
really seem like they hurt him they're
just kind of like a visual curiosity he
Sparks them together like a kid playing
with flint and steel or matches and then
we get the slapstick humor of him
slicing the sink in the pipes and it
just kind of feels like Peter Parker in
the first Spider-Man film splooging webs
all over his bedroom like Logan
screaming in pain at the alkal lake lab
and then fighting his way free that
should have been enough of a Powers orig
story this bathroom scene's just kind of
goofy and comedic and it's really just
not who Logan is and Travis is the one
who gives Logan his son's jacket this is
the same jacket that we saw him wearing
to the first few scenes of the original
X-Men film and the stripes on the arms
are reminiscent of his original costume
in the comics we never find out what
happened to the Hudson's son and we're
never going to either because right
after this touchy moment Agent Zero
murders them both and it is awful now we
got to talk about the second most insane
sequence of this film Wolverine facing
down agent Zero's helicopter and
avenging his Canadian Brethren and I
just love how Logan is using his new
claws in this scene he drags them in the
dirt for like a quick turn on his
motorcycle and then he uses them in this
joust method to kind of Lance the side
of the armored car to send it flipping
and then he leaps from the armored car
that explodes and he flies physics Dam
directly into the helicopter rotors and
then claw the blades to send the
helicopter crashing and then the whole
scene ends with him slow motion walking
away from the thing as it explodes
behind him I mean come on it's 2009 at
least when Iron Man did this he was like
a 100 yards away from that tank and he
was armored but really my issue with the
sequence is that Wolverine is
essentially fastball specialing himself
what makes him going airborne so fun is
that he needs someone else to throw him
like Colossus it's really the same joke
in Two Towers of gimy quietly telling
Aragon TOS me followed by don't tell the
elf so the fact that Logan is now just
doing all of this alone is just kind of
I guess this movie statement on how
Weapon X turned him into a oneman army
just a pure demonstration of strength we
don't really learn anything new about
him as a character other than yeah he he
was strong and I guess there's a time of
his life where he didn't need the X-Men
which is why it's so weird in this movie
that we get origin stories of other
X-Men like Cyclops he's given something
of an origin story in this movie
refusing to take his sunglasses off
getting a headache during Spanish class
when they're trying to conjugate the
verb ablar which is to talk perhaps
these headaches are actually coming from
Charles XE avior talk to this young
mutant to warn him of Victor Creed
coming for him because we learn in Logan
these kind of psionic brain waves are
what caused most of the X-Men to die now
while Logan's memory is wiped in this
movie by the magic Adam Anum bullet this
implied that this young Scott Summers
would grow up to be James Marsden
Cyclops who remember fight saber-tooth
in the first X-Men film whether either
of them would remember their past in the
early 80s it doesn't come up at the
Spectre boxing gym Logan has a little
reunion with John wraith and Fred Dukes
who now looks much more like his comic
book self wearing a save the whale shirt
while drinking a Slurpee behind the ring
is a sign that reads Phantom weight
that's between fly weight and
featherweight or between 112 and 118 lbs
and it lists Two fighters Ray Perez and
Troy Walters both names of real boxers
though as far as I can tell they never
fought each other this scene of Logan in
the ring with dukes calls back to the
blob's comic book introduction he
invited people to try to move him and no
one could make him fudge except
Wolverine is just built differently and
takes advantage of his new adamantium
skeleton Wolverine finds out that Victor
and Striker have been working together
this whole time and this whole thing was
a long con to get him to agree to be
part of the weapon x experiment where's
Victor with Striker on on the island
they they they they they run it together
Victor will be with
Striker yeah
yeah he he didn't know that just like in
the first X film we get a point of view
shot of Logan's claw coming straight out
and on Bourbon Street in New Orleans we
finally get to see Gambit Remy leau
played by Taylor kitch who as the star
of Friday Night Lights in the late OTS
was supposed to be the big new star of
Hollywood in movies like John Carter and
you know what I miss this guy Gambit was
planned to make a appearances in the
three previous X-Men films was
ultimately always left out and then
after this the Channing Tatum spin-off
movie was sheld it's kind of a bummer
kit rocks in this movie and at the table
real poker player Daniel negru cameos is
playing against gamit in a deleted scene
Victor is able to track Logan and wraith
to New Orleans presumably because he
beat it out of The Blob it'll be out of
the equation in 24 hours can you
guarantee that oh yes sir how because
I'll know where he's going right before
Victor kills wraith when wraith
teleports you can see his skeleton
coming into place for first and then his
skin covers it a split second later it's
a really weird but really cool effect
and then Victor collects wraith's DNA
for Deadpool and I like the steps that
they make in this movie to make the
teleportation of wraith different than
the teleportation of B the Nightcrawler
the Nightcrawler one is smokier because
he's going through the brimstone
Dimension but wraith doesn't teleport
the same way Victor tells Logan tell me
something Jimmy you even know how to
kill me I'm going to cut your goddamn
head off in the Comics Wolverine
actually does kill saber-tooth by
cutting his head off Gambit gets between
the brothers with his charged bow staff
and he does a similar move with it that
Ray parked it as toad with the pipe in
the first X-Men film then Wolverine
immediately calls back the move he did
the first X-Men film flipping someone
off using the middle Adam anim clock
that's a nice
stick we see a younger version of
Striker's son Jason Striker who we saw
in X2 Jason is a powerful mutant based
on Mastermind in the comics who could
control and alter minds and here as he
does in that movie has differently
colored eyes Striker had brought him to
Xavier's School in the hopes that he
could cure him but this would be after
he left the school and after his wife
took her own life with the power drill
now there are more mutants Frozen in the
other tanks but we can't really see them
as well General mson checks out weapon
11 AKA Deadpool all their strengths and
none of their weaknesses in Marvel lore
this is actually how a half mutant half
vampire blade is described you got the
best of both world all our
strengths none of our weaknesses but yes
this is nothing like Deadpool's origin
story in the comics it does involve the
weapon x program but it's more
Faithfully adapted in the 2016 Deadpool
film Gambit flies Logan a strike Three
Mile Island hiding in plain s side no
one's going to Snoop around a nuclear
reactor they think it's going to turn
him into freaks in 2013 The Wolverine
Logan actually survives an atomic blast
at Nagasaki in World War II so yes like
many soldiers and Marines who fought in
Europe during World War II our man
relocated to the Pacific Theater at the
worst possible time so Logan jumps out
of this plane without a parachute just
like Captain America does in the Winter
Soldier Logan looks much less graceful
though he hits the water and he skids
along it like a rock and we get the
reveal that Kayla is still alive and
that she is a mutant and Logan is
devastated but Striker was manipulating
her too her sister was one of the
mutants he kidnapped and he held that
over Kayla to get her to do what he
wanted a deleted scene would have shown
Striker asking Logan to let him wipe his
memory to forget about Kayla and all the
other horrible things that had happened
in his life and Logan agreeing let's do
it but that was ultimately left out
because it felt too bad of character for
Logan to let Striker do that to him
Logan walks away but comes back when he
hears Kayla's truly horrifying
scream and I think that one of the
reasons he was so protective of Rogue
and X-Men was that she reminded him on a
subconscious level of Cayla both their
powers rely on human touch Kaya tells
the story of how the Wolverine can never
touch the moon and Rogue can never get
close to or touch anyone she cares about
and both women were manipulated by
powerful men for their own means the
relationship with Rogue was obviously
meant to be like a big brother little
sister but when vulnerable women are put
In Harm's Way Logan really loses his
damn mind Logan and Victor fight again
but Logan walks away because he's not an
animal Kayla and Logan freed the other
mutants and strikker prison in keeping
in mind that some of this movie gets
reccon later and the timeline doesn't
really make sense once first class is in
the mix here are the mutants we see the
red-haired mutant with the handable
Lector type mask over his mouth is
presumably Sean Cassidy AKA Banshee he
shows up in first class some folks claim
that this is supposed to be the mutant
chamber but chamers Powers come from his
chest not his mouth so that really
wouldn't make that much sense this
character is not named in the credits so
I think this is supposed to be Banshee
but when Banshee appeared in first class
they kind of reton or ignored this the
kid with the lizard tongue and the
amphibious eyes is presumably a young
Mortimer toin be a toad the girl with
the freezing powers in a cell with frost
and icicles is likely Ice Princess the
kid who looks like he's causing a
tornado in a cell is Rip tied he also
shows up in first class the mutant who's
tied up trying to break free is Peter
maximoff quick silver you can see his
white hair there he will be played by
Evan Peters in Days of Future Past in
the MCU version is played by Aaron
Taylor Johnson and Age of Ultron there's
a mutant with blue and purple streaks in
her hair whom people assumed was psylock
there's two Mutant twins not sure about
them and of course there's Scott Summers
and Kayla's sister Emma Silver Fox with
the diamond skin because because yeah
she's pretty much Emma Frost in this
movie weapon 11 blocks the mutants from
escaping and we get our first real look
at the Deadpool design Alec Gillis and
Tom woodriff Jr from Studio ADI these
are the guys who created this Deadpool
look talked about the design that at the
time was much maligned by fans so if
you're looking at him as Deadpool I can
understand why you'd be disappointed he
doesn't have the costume he doesn't he's
not that character that you know and
love from the comic books what the
studio was trying to do I think was set
up the character of Deadpool uh uh for
the future this is sort of a pre-
Deadpool they wanted um you know him to
look like a like a patient like a like a
sort of a patient SL victim uh of the
scientific process and to be fair to
them they were just doing their job and
they trying to carry out the Studio's
Vision weapon 11 has adamantium swords
that retract into his arms much has been
made about the fact that adamantium
doesn't Bend given the length of these
swords he wouldn't been able to bend his
arms but I guess we talked that up to
everyone just thinking armed swords
would look cool and not worrying about
the logistics weapon 11 has Logan's
healing ability John R's power of
teleportation Scott summers's optic
blasts and when he uses his optic blasts
the skin around his eyes chars in a
diamond pattern the same kind of pattern
that Deadpool wears on his mask in the
comics of course this version of
Deadpool would lead Ryan Reynolds to
reconceive the character in his own
films with an aggressive fan campaign in
a viral proof of concept video and I
would argue that Deadpool film would not
have been successful if this one didn't
go so poorly of course he has never
shied away from this controversial
design what do you do us all a favor and
shut the up well so your pretty
mouth shut
oh I wouldn't do that if I were you they
have embraced this history so much that
this initial moment when Logan and
weapon 11 come face to face would later
be Revisited and parody in the
post-credit Montage of Deadpool 2 in
2018 when Deadpool time travels back to
this moment to kill his alternate self
in a tease that will almost certainly
set up their reunion in Deadpool 3 one
day your old pal Wade's going to ask you
to get back in the saddle
again and when he does say yes Charles
Xavier meanwhile communicates with Scott
telepathically set up his uncredited
Cameo at the end of the film Victor
saves Logan and they fight weapon 11
together back to back as they were
before and they decapitate weapon 11 who
severed head continues to fire an optic
blast that destroys the cooling tower I
mean it's crazy but I got of love it
Striker loads up a few adamantium
bullets into his gun knowing that they
won't kill Logan but also that if he
shoots him in the head his memories
won't grow back it's very silly in the
comic Origin Wolverine loses his memory
temporarily but this was due to his
healing powers protecting him from
mental stress and that I believe would
have been a much cooler explanation
because our memories do work that way
our memories will warp and erase
themselves in ways that will make us
stronger in the present this is just a
natural biological and psychological
function that we all go through and you
can imagine Wolverine having a far more
regenerative healing form of it so Kayla
dies for real this time but not before
using her powers on Striker to make him
Point his gun at himself like Magneto in
the cops in the first film I should make
you pull the trigger but that would make
us no better than you throw the gun away
turn around walk into your feet bleed
and then keep keep walking oh my God
this is like some killgrave will do
in Jessica Jones or that character in
gen V does accidentally to her brother
in the mid credit scene we catch up with
Striker as he is doing exactly this but
he gets arrested for questioning over
general mson I'm not sure why he's able
to stop and turn around and it also
really isn't clear how he avoids blame
for this in between this movie and his
appearance the next two and Patrick
Stewart makes his big Cameo he is deaged
again less successfully than he is in
the Last Stand and even though that
scene was set in 1985 or 1986 this would
just be a few years before that in the
early ' 80s they could have used
literally the same design or maybe just
not shown the character's head and just
used Patrick Stewart's iconic voice it's
clear that they just did not have the
same budget for this movie but look
closely at this whole scene the entire
scene with the helicopter and the kids
running up in that background all of
this is with CGI and bfx and it's very
clearly all rushed and it's just
something artificial about it now X-Men
first Class would established that
Charles Xavier L his ability to walk
years earlier but Days of Future Past
established that he could walk again
using a serum during the 1970s either
way this timeline would get rcon so that
Charles looked exactly like James maer
booy during the' 70s in the 1980s in the
post credit scene weapon 11 grabs his
own decapitated head from the
rubble so the skin around his mouth is
now open and he shushes us why does he
do that I don't know I suppose they
wanted the Merc with the mouth to
finally have a mouth and to know when
and when not to use it but what they
intended his Arc to be from this point
forward isn't exactly clear on the X-Men
Origins Wolverine DVD there is an
alternate post cred scene that shows
Logan drinking in a bar in
Japan no
I'm drinking to remember this would be a
setup to 2013's The Wolverine directed
by James Mangold which is set in Japan
so next week will be our breakdown of
X-Men first Class but first some
Deadpool 3 spoilers in the danger room
so let's talk about Wade and Logan these
two faed off in this doorway in Three
Mile Island and the fact that it comes
back in Deadpool 2 makes X-Men Origins
Wolverine an essential chapter to
rewatch Deadpool 3 is almost certainly
going to touch back on this movie quite
a bit Wade's previous appearance and
power set other members of Team X the
way that this movie says Wolverine got
his name the really bad VFX on Charles
the adamantium bullet it's so crazy and
so wonderful you know they're going to
bring some of this back in Deadpool 3
comment down below with what you love
still about this movie and give this
video a like And subscribe to new rock
stars because not only are we going to
be doing rewatch of this movie series
let us know in the comments below what
movie series you want us to revisit next
we've done an Infinity Saga rewatch
before but there's plenty of other great
movie franchise series out there that
you know we need to revisit I'm Eric
Voss thanks for watching and I'll see
you next week stick bye
[Music]